[Music]
mexico city's metropolitan area
is home to over 21 million people for
decades it has been plagued by
increasing overpopulation
and serious air pollution its streets
are gridlocked access to drinkable water
is scarce
and left unattended the city is expected
to dry out within the next 30 years
crime is on the rise and the gap between
the rich and the poor
is massive and only increasing abject
poverty is rampant
but there's a new mayor in town and she
has
big plans for its future i hope to solve
many many problems
the city it's innovation innovation for
me is the use of science and technology
to change
the way things work
scheimbaum is the first woman to be
elected mayor of mexico city
but that's not necessarily the most
interesting part of her story
because she's not just an ordinary
politician she's a nobel peace
prize-winning scientist
with an ambitious vision for this
troubled metropolis
my mother she is also a scientist she's
a biologist by biochemistry it was very
important for me in my formation
i have a master and a phd in energy
engineering
i always like math and nature
most of my academic life i studied
climate change and
energy the relation with energy and
climate change
alongside her strong scientific
background young claudia was raised to
be passionate about politics
politics has been always part of my
family
our conversations in one sense science
teach you
to question everything in politics it's
very very important to understand
why it's something happening
how to convince people of the ideas that
you think
are the real ideas to change your
country
scheinbaum pressed on with political
activism while thriving in her academic
career in energy engineering
for two decades in the year 2000 she
served her first public appointment
as the secretary of the environment of
mexico city
she jointly received the nobel peace
prize in 2007
as a member of the intergovernmental
panel on climate change
then later became mayor of mexico city's
borough slalopan from 2015 to 2017.
the following year she was elected mayor
of the whole city
today her passion for science and
political action has culminated
into a six-year plan to fundamentally
transform mexico city
into a cleaner more equitable place for
its 21 million inhabitants
i want for my city in the six years that
i'm going to be
the chief of government to develop
the access to rights not only education
health
but also culture sports
environment
the city is very unequal what i want for
the city is to reduce these
inequalities how to do that access to
rights
where they don't have and a better
environment
including resources to the poorest part
of the city
the mayor's grand vision includes seven
primary goals
reducing air pollution by 30 percent
planting
15 million trees banning single-use
plastics and promoting recycling
building a new waste separation plant
for the city
providing water service to every home
constructing a hundred kilometers of
corridors for public transportation
and constructing and installing solar
water heaters and solar panels city-wide
so that's a lot but despite the scale of
these ambitions
mayor scheinbaum has aligned herself
with mexico's president lopez obrador
as an advocate for drastic cuts in
government spending
you cannot have a rich government and a
poor people so what we did is
reduce government then you have a lot of
resources
for infrastructure and also for
different actions
we built a new university in the city in
two years
you need a lot of money where do you get
this money we didn't increase
taxes so you get this money reducing the
government
and the other thing is stop corruption
we feel like a citizen governing
citizens
we don't have any luxuries in our
government and this brings you a lot of
resources to bring to the people and to
reduce inequalities
hopefully you know in these six years i
can change
many things in the city public
transportation build parks
have digital access to many people
if you are able to change people
and to give opportunity to young people
then the city is going to be different
for the next years
mexico city has been hit hard by covid
19 with over 156
000 cases and 15 000 deaths as of
october of 2020
and while lofty government plans have
often fallen to the wayside this year
mayor scheinbaum has managed to
implement parts of her vision while
handling the public health crisis
this is best seen on the avenue of the
insurgents
mexico city's largest and busiest street
where bike lanes popped up
just as fast as the traffic died down
from quarantine
it's a very commercial street we're
asking restaurants and
business and everybody if they agree to
keep it
i want for everybody to be part of this
so that's what we're doing right now
still there is little doubt that 2020
was not the kind of start that the mayor
had hoped for
for her administration but as mexico
city's first female mayor
she is used to some obstacles and
overcoming them
has become somewhat of a preoccupation
of hers
mexico has the culture of machismo you
can feel as a woman that you're less
that you're not able to do anything
because everybody tells you
you're less than this man and as long as
you think that you're able to do it
it brings you the the strength to do it
paseo de la reforma is one of the main
avenues
you have many monuments they are only
men
right now we are building the women
heroines
it's the rescuing of women in history
it only makes sense that mayor
scheinbaum will face opposition against
her ambitious vision for mexico city
but her faith in science and its ability
to address
inequality and corruption in her city to
the benefit of her countrymen
remains unshakable
we believe in social change by
convincing people
we believe that mexico has a great
future
we end corruption in the country and we
believe that
education health and housing are rights
they are not merchandise
[Music]
you